good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy
thursday after hurricane ida over here
in new york
hope everyone is okay yeah lots of
flooding some crazy videos crazy times
hope everyone is doing okay may i ask
you a question is this a piece of
information that everyone knew was
happening
well
not i didn't know i only progressively
knew from like storm warnings and then
starting to see some stuff on social
media but like you got the flash flood
alert yes but the storm had already
started like right i'm spending you know
living my life no but like i was outside
last night because we recorded redheads
late last night right we went home at
like 8 30 and it was raining sideways i
didn't know that was hurricane ida me
neither i get dressed to call me brian
for dinner you know of course i live in
a bunker i have no windows i'm like oh i
bet it's hot outside i should wear
shorts
i get all dressed up and i walk out it's
torrential and i'm like holy [ __ ] and i
go downtown as i'm driving on the fdr
like i'm scared i'm like this is crazy
yeah i had no idea and then i literally
got stuck downtown till 2 a.m i could
not get a car it was crazy lightning i
was like in a building with windows so
refreshing
literally crazy ass lighting everyone's
phones in the restaurant were going off
at the same time with like the flash
flood warning and i was like why the
[ __ ] did i leave my house and nobody
told me like i didn't know i didn't know
either i mean you know who i blame blame
it on the weather sniff that is such a
[ __ ] good song blame it on the
weatherman yeah because like she gives
us the weather every day she did tell us
was gonna rain all day but she didn't
tell us that we were united's past no
she maybe maybe she gets her information
also like from some bad sources and i
just think we should always be blaming
it on the weatherman because the
weatherman never knows what the [ __ ]
he's talking about ever ever um but you
know brian when we were together he
lives on the delaware literally his
entire property's underwater like it's
[ __ ] crazy oh my god i said his
pickup truck is gone like he doesn't
know where it is oh my god crazy so like
it's worse for other people yeah it's
but it was worse outside of the city in
the burrows too but i just have to say
the weather we're having today is so
glorious it's one of the days where
you're like
i could never leave new york in the fall
you know it's gorgeous outside 66 slight
breeze yeah it really is nice and we're
just cruising into fall and you guys we
deserve it after the summer that we put
up with no i cannot wait i'm telling you
i mean i'm sure this won't actually come
true but like my [ __ ] false style is
going to be sickening like we'll see if
that's
sweatshirts yeah like i'm done i'm done
wearing this [ __ ] like i know that looks
like fall style this was my foray into
fall i'm falling into fall but this is
like old you know stuff i need new stuff
okay new sweatshirts new leggings not
leggings [ __ ] like i want to wear cool
lots like i'm going to be a fashionista
i want to wear like
trousers do it i would love to see you
in a pair of trousers you know what i do
think it's time and i know like people
have said this to me specifically in the
past
as an insult i do think i need a stylist
like how do people consistently have new
clothes
i've been wearing the same [ __ ] since
like literal high school yeah
i okay do it i need a rotating wardrobe
i'm an on-air camera person get a
stylist
reach out you guys but only if you shop
at like asos i can't be spending lots of
money on clothes yeah no i'm sure you
could find someone yeah that's fun i
want like um i actually feel like that's
a really good business to start i feel
like it actually exists it's whatever
but like
someone who shops online for you
i find it exhausting my eyes hurt after
a while so hard to be you
so incredibly difficult you have no
[ __ ] idea and i just wanted to say
i'm really proud of myself because when
i figured i was like 10 30 i realized i
was not gonna get home for a while last
night i was so far from home literally
edge of the city
and i was like all right i guess we're
just gonna have to get [ __ ] up and i
and i did just that um not only did i
get home at two o'clock
take my makeup off managed to remember
to take advil drank a bottle of water
woke up not hungover watch your house
sides of beverly hills and got here on
time i'm proud of myself i'm proud of
you too and i'm glad for it because
we've got a lot to do today
and hungover claudia just wouldn't be up
to the task and honestly like
i think this is what we call like
growing up i'm kind of over hungover
claudia
she's like kind of disgusting
you're laughing because you agree
no i would never have used that word
that's not how i perceive her maybe not
disgusting but like she's [ __ ]
useless okay
and then it's just like
i don't know like a waste of a show
and we're like taking so many days off
these days like we can't be wasting [ __ ]
it's like
take a day off if you're gonna waste a
show take a day off enjoy it go
somewhere
totally
so that's that's i think that's called
growth i'm really excited to hear it you
know sometimes hungover claudia once in
a while
yeah always a fun time
she came here a lot this summer no she
was visiting super frequently but i did
warn everyone i said you didn't
when we're living in a post-pandemic
world
not without warning yeah but i think
i've kind of evolved past that like if i
want to get [ __ ] up like i'm just not
coming in
fine i think that's what it's going to
be okay that's fine
so that's what you get sweet
um what did you do yesterday oh i
started that book you recommended sorry
i cannot stop talking over you the
lion's den okay i'm like really not deep
into it yet like i haven't gotten the
hook yet i mean it's cute and fun
they're on a private plane like i cannot
complain but i haven't been reeled in
okay you'll be reeled and then you'll be
reeled again and like maybe again once
more oh wow it's pretty it's like a long
book it just keeps like it's cheap it's
like five hours okay but like if you
like it then you shouldn't want it to
end so quickly it's good i think you'll
like it because there's a lot of
fabulosity and that's really your
criteria yesterday was a busy day for me
because we recorded the redheads last
night we recapped and discussed we are
the brennans which was a really great
book and it's such a fun episode of the
redheads we all we came here to the
studio we had dinner first which is like
my new would you eat
seraphina [ __ ] i had chipper gummy last
night jackie cuberani is like the best
restaurant i totally forgot to mention i
had the cake obviously i had the fattest
[ __ ] dinner of all time like do you
have pasta well let's start familiar i
ate the whole bread basket need to go to
chip brownie because i need a salad to
start exactly it was so [ __ ] like me
to pasta and then i need the cake and
ready the new chip around in downtown
has pizza
it was okay so i ate a whole bread
literally a whole bread basket the guy
was like should we bring another one i'm
like yes there are more people coming
ate the whole bread basket then a
margarita pizza that was
so heavenly like i could have plotzed
then i got this i forget what the pasta
was called but it was basically marinara
and cream so it's like a pink sauce
and they gave it family style it was
like the biggest platter ever oh my god
it was so family of one literally
it was so
good and then i was so full so we like
sat at the table for a while and kept
drinking and then you know i wasn't full
anymore so we got the cake
and
the cake jackie it was better than i
remembered wow it was so [ __ ] good
wow did you ate surfing yeah you just
you're eating too good and i can't hear
it
it's just like it's not right the way
like especially last week i realized
like you just eat so good and like
now that i'm so what do you think what
do you mean in tune with like what i'm
eating and all i'm looking for it's like
a good meal like you're just constantly
being fed like delicious gourmet like
olivia is cooking for you ben's cooking
for you oh yeah
and like
i'm ordering seraphina again okay i just
have to say like stick with me first of
all that's what we're learning
throughout your pregnancy
and second of all i was literally
talking about this last night with brian
i'm like you guys me and jackie have
never been better like we are so similar
now that she's pregnant like she's tired
she's hungry and like i can just finally
relate to her so honestly like we've got
to go to tripiani that's the lesson we
do i i forgot how much i love gibriani
at every location and there's so many
and they're all so different but they're
all stellar a new one opened downtown
and
jackie i was the best one i've been to
oh really
there's so many
the one the downtown one like the west
broadway one is like the cool one and
it's good yeah but i also i love the one
at the mr c hotel i think the pasta
there is on in beverly hills no no the
mr c in new york oh where is there's a
mr seed like down by the seaport
that's where i was
maybe
the hotel yeah but i don't think it's
called a mr c it is there's so many
different brands under the cipriani like
umbrella i can't it's confusing but but
it's called the whole the whole building
is called casa cipriani and it's a hotel
brian was staying there last night so i
went to a hotel room oh so maybe they
rebranded was it was it a mr c it was a
mr c i love the mrc in beverly hills
except the beds are too small for four
sisters to stay in one room which is
what we learned yeah because you they
said two queen beds i'm like okay we're
sisters two of us can bunk not queen
beds they're fools at best fool's at
best they're a large twin jackie will
refer to like a bed that's like an odd
shape as a mr seabed no like there is a
shape of bed that is not even a full
because i had a full in college and like
that was freaking huge a full is really
similar to a queen yeah but there is a
size bed that is a little bit smaller
than a full a little bit bigger than a
twin and it's called a mr c bed because
they have them in mr c and we were all
just like miserable that whole weekend
like it was such a fun trip and every
time we got back to the room we're like
ugh
mr steve what are we sharing with
tonight like get away
that is [ __ ] funny yeah um so yeah we
got to eat good like we did not go to
lunch yesterday like you promised me
okay because you didn't want to go
either no i was just like kind of tired
i was just ready to get home to brew
like i miss him so much i'm just like
have brew attachment today we need to
watch shrek 2 because we bought shrek
the other day brew and i and he was
cracking up over donkey he was like this
man gets me i was like yeah bru like you
are donkey shrek is really good shrek is
really good we were influenced by kaye
and so i i just it was so enjoyable to
watch shrek one
alone sober adult so good so now we need
to watch shrek 2 and i really think brew
is going to love puss in boots i'm so
excited for brew to meet puss
in boots puffs puss in boots puss in
boots
pus is like the things that come out of
your pinball yeah puss is it cause he's
[ __ ] he's a cat
yeah puss he's really inappropriate it's
actually like not kid friendly no the
whole movie is so is the most double
entendre yeah of all
everything and that's how parents that's
how like the movie studios get the
parents to take their kids to the movies
yes but most of the cartoons are not
like that like we watch moana all
weekend because that's miss kay's
favorite
oh my god i have it i've had it stuck in
my head since then like and not in a
good way
and
it's not
underlying raunchiness like shrek shrek
is on another level i agree yeah shrek
is like actually for adults yeah
or like at least when we saw it we
weren't watching a lot of cartoons it
was like we were beyond the cartoon age
but like the the movie slapped yeah it's
like alan gregory it's like the prince
gregory cartoons for adults
another day goes by that i don't think
about alan gregory so brew and i need to
get to watching shark too because he's
like what happens with yon and trek like
so you're saying we can't have lunches
what the message we could but you'll
have to talk to brew okay i'll my people
will talk to your people sweet um we
have a great show for you guys today we
do have the real housewives of beverly
hills recap the dinner party from hill
which was a very good episode and we're
gonna be recapping that along with the
past five so i do think without further
uh
ado
it is time for the past five stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast
and today's episode is brought to you by
spritz society your favorite well your
new favorite canned cocktail sparkling
wine six percent abv
started by yours truly and we've got a
labor day sale coming up um the code is
labor day 15 at spritsociety.com 15 off
the entire website so if you're looking
to throw a bbq or just have some people
over try to stock your fridge with some
premium beverages that also are stunning
to look at try sports society we come in
four flavors we've got pineapple
grapefruit lemonade and blood orange
they're fabulous there's a flavor for
everyone they're sparkling wine based so
we ship to most u.s states head to
support society.com and also use the
code labor day 15 for 15 off you know we
have a code toast here obviously but
this labor day sale is better than ours
so i'm not pro i'm not pushing kotos i'm
pushing code labor day 15 and it won't
last long spritsociety.com thank you
claudia a pleasure
okay first story olivia jade gianouli
and bachelor matt james reportedly
joined dancing with the stars
gianouli was spotted being escorted into
the rehearsal studio tuesday in a video
published by tmz which reported that her
pro partner appeal appears to be val
chermkovsky meanwhile james matt james
has also been added to the lineup for
the upcoming season of the abc dance
competition show us weekly reported it
is unclear who he'll be paired with i
mean this really is not a rumor because
there's video evidence and i'm just like
taking a minute
to ingest all of this for matt james to
do it that's not surprising after he
people on the bachelor go all the time
it's a great way to boost your fame matt
and
you know has been doing a lot of that
after his time on the bachelor makes
total sense he hasn't been doing that
much but okay really yeah i feel like
him and rachel are really low-key and
like they just like you know ride around
new york on their um bicycles and are
just living life that's so interesting
that that's your living life but they go
to cool events because they're invited
to cool events but i don't feel like
they're on the the typical bachelor
tract of like
they're smart strings that's very
interesting i don't see it like that's
not how it's been perceived for me okay
but
nevertheless him going on dancing with
the stars is it the natural order of
things yes but this olivia jade thing is
throwing me through the loop whatever
the phrase is like
i don't know why this just like makes no
sense because obviously it makes sense
in the sense that like she's an
influencer she has this like big scandal
whatever but people who come on dancing
with the stars there is an element of
desperation that olivia jade does not
currently or
not nor has she ever possessed like at
the end of the day
she's
rich as hell and she's like living life
so i just it's like
people who go on dancing with the stars
either like on their way up or on their
way down trying to bounce back and yes
olivia jade could probably use that
bounce back after like the college
admissions drama but i don't know i just
feel like she's better than this
okay i mean i hear why you say that
because we always say like you know and
dancing with the stars really did start
as like celebrity wasteland but i do
think now it's a lot
it's a lot cooler like for sure from the
people that have come out of it and like
the success that they've had from it and
olivia
in she's been back for a while now it's
been a long time since you know she came
back it's been a long time since red
table talk and like
she's nowhere
and i think like she yes she needs a
boost she needs a boost and she her
family like they're fine and it's not
about the money but like if she wants to
have a career she needs to do [ __ ] like
this that's very true and i feel like
this is actually like a fun thing a fun
thing to do like as far as desperate
activities go you know like yeah dancing
with the stars you could do a depends
commercial like i'd rather do dancing
with the stars i guess that's true no
and dancing with the stars has come a
long way it used to really be for people
who were on the way down in their career
but honestly now it's like a 50 people
on the way down and 50 people on the way
up so they've made huge progress in and
like jojo c was on this season and it's
a good season i wouldn't say that she is
uh going up or down i feel like she's
just she's a star she's a star and
she'll be dancing with the stars
makes sense
um so i was just really surprised to
hear this
yeah but you're right like it does make
sense
it's hard when you have a scandal of
that magnitude because even though time
passes you are left in this like vortex
that you can't get out of because it's
like always the thing you're going to be
remembered for so maybe i don't know if
she like slips or she has to change the
narrative yeah she's like she can't do
that while like you know just taking
vlogs instagram mirror pictures and even
not even the vlogs because she's very
she's done like five since her comeback
she's very sparse exactly also some of
the other contestants who are on for
this season jojo siwa kenya moore
shut up olympian suny lee oh she's
winning that's actually like no and the
talk co-host amanda cloots who is a
dancer she is right she used to post all
those dancing videos she posts all those
dancing videos i think you're confusing
her with like another like
influencer who does like dance workouts
who i don't know but she doesn't like
plotting she's the influencer who did
dance workouts and then she became like
so much more than that but like she's
the dancer absolutely in my opinion has
the biggest leg up here or jojo siwa
jojo siwa actually she came from dance
moms she's a classically trained dancer
keep that in mind so was amanda cloots i
believe like i think if we go to a man
includes wikipedia like she's
pleased
i'm pretty sure she's a pilates
a expert not a dance expert
amanda cloots is an american television
personality dancer and fitness
instructor but her fitness was her
dancing i understood the dancing was a
lot of jumping around not like dancing
with the stars i understand
okay
no it's it's actually shaping up to be
quite a competitive
cast yeah but we have this conversation
every year relevant yes we have this
conversation every year about like is it
really fair like of course i want sunita
lee to win and she probably will like
she's literally like there's nothing she
can't do she doesn't have to like a lot
of people really go on and struggle with
like the constant like the working out a
lot of people drop a lot of weight like
sunily's been in olympic training for
four years like this is nothing yeah so
she does have an unfair advantage but
simone biles was on did she win
no i don't think she won and people
thought lori hernandez was on and i do
believe she won
so it's not like a guarantee but
remember heather mars that's the t like
the iconic example the girl money was on
yeah that's crazy and she didn't win
yeah that's crazy that is crazy that
just goes to show like yeah no it goes
to show like that it's rigged
um normani's like the best dancer of all
time yeah
and she didn't win dancing with the
stars that's actually really funny also
when it comes to dancing with the stars
i um
i had something to say and it was worth
saying so just give me 45 seconds okay
take take all the time that you need
dancing with the stars
now dancing with stars reminds me of
that kanye song
i can't be out here dancing with the
stars wait what were you talking about
it was like right in my brain normani
heather morris
simone biles amanda klutz
yeah it's coming back wait
whatever i hope abby lee miller shows up
to root for jojo yeah you know she's
jojo's biggest fan is she
she's come around
even though like
abby lee really didn't see in jojo what
the world saw in jojo abby like rejected
her she like left like she was not
popular or liked by
abby lee in abby lee's defense
if i may and i don't watch dance moms
and i don't i didn't see joe joe's
departure but you feel compelled to
speak on i feel compelled just from at a
glance okay abby lee's job was to find
the best dancer yes what jojo does now
does not have to do with being the best
answer no but also i'm so glad you
brought that up because i could
literally write a dissertation on this
yes while it was abby lee miller's job
to find the best answer she was truly
clouded by so many other things that
like
it was first of all she played favorites
based on talent but also just based on
like personality and then the mom's
getting involved like if she hated your
mom like she hated you too like like
honestly chloe lucasiac was like always
right behind maddie like maddie was
always on top of the pyramid and chloe
was like right behind even though like
they really were like both equally
talented but i just don't think abby
liked her mom christy and like that just
added like a whole other political
element so yes while it was a talent
competition abby wasn't always a fair
judge
fine and the more so what i'm saying the
more seasons that went on abby became
more and more delusional fine not what
i'm saying at all but like the success
that jojo has had has been about her as
a person not as a dancer not her not her
dancing you no i agreed with that there
was just another element in your
sentence i just wanted to correct sure
it sounds like you have like a bone to
pick with like with dance moms like i
think we all do
not me because i didn't watch you are so
missing out jack i know you've told me
that but claude i just can't okay now i
told you years ago no offense you're too
old to watch it now no you told me it a
few months ago too and i said i would
watch it but like i'm not going to maybe
you weren't pregnant yet because now
that you're pregnant you can't watch
dance moms my kid could watch it
literally okay next up some sad news
andy cohen and the real housewives of
atlanta stars send love to nene leakes
after her husband greg dies of colon
cancer
greg leakes died at age 66 following a
battle with colon cancer publicist and
longtime family friend ernst
confirmed in a wednesday statement
this is so sad so sad a few days ago it
was reported that he was like on the
decline it was happening quickly nene
opened a club in atlanta called lenithia
lounge and she did like an event there
and i guess someone recorded it or just
like told it to tmz that she basically
is like i've been mia like my husband
has been dying and i'm just like
watching the person that i love just
slowly
die
and then literally two days later
so [ __ ] sad so sad i was like hit
really hard by it you know i think a lot
of people were because he was like nene
like has been you know insufferable on
the show she's been great on the show
but greg has like always just been like
her ride or die i think a lot of people
were like really moved by their love
story they got divorced and remarried
like i don't know i just i feel so
profoundly sad about this yeah
and i know everyone else andy left like
a a really nice message on his twitter
even though like i don't believe him and
nini are even on speaking terms oh
that's so interesting yeah but he said
i'm heartbroken over the passing of greg
leakes a wonderful man i jokingly called
him pastor leaks but in truth he was a
strong voice of reason and commanded
great respect among the entire real
houses of atlanta team i'm sending love
and strength to nene and the entire
leagues family i do hope that like he
reached out and maybe this could be a
bridge it would be great and you know
like
during the end of her time on the show
nene was so mean and so unhappy and
it's almost like easy to look past that
now like knowing what she was going
through with greg like i would any
person would be
terrible to their friends like so i do
feel like nene actually does deserve a
second chance and i just can't believe
that like greg beat cancer you know and
then like all was good and then it
wasn't yeah
ugh i'm so upset by this
and
i don't know like sad for their kids and
nene and it's just really sad because he
was like the best he was really integral
in bringing kim zolciak and nini back
together like he was just a good man
like he really was a lovely lovely
gentleman yeah and i'm
deep like i know she's not on the show
anymore but like the world and the
franchise everything will suffer without
greg leaks and i'm i'm so sad yes i
agree his absence will definitely be
felt regardless of her presence or not
on the show yeah
and i hope all the ladies are properly i
i a lot of them have a lot of beef like
historical beef yes but i think this is
one of those things where like the beef
is set aside because you know it's
usually pretty superficial beef and it's
like housewife drama and this and that
no this is like jill bobby and bethany
yes that's where everyone kind of had
their rapper schmall yes exactly exactly
okay our next story in katie thurston is
reacting to michelle young's glam
bachelorette
so michelle young's bachelorette promo
drop yesterday and it is flames
okay sickening you know what it is it's
opulent it's budget it's a budget it's a
little mixed song it's perfect like it
was just stunning it really was like the
the creme de la creme of even like in
the height of bachelor days who who got
the best promos when you think of the
best promos you've heard of hannah brown
like this was everything like that and
we thought those days were over because
of katie thurston's promo the t-shirt
yeah team katie so katie
wrote y'all i wore a rubber purple skirt
backwards which was a shout out to my
vibrator regardless i found love and i
hope michelle does too wait
that skirt was a metaphor for her
vibrator i thought it was just ugly
maybe it was like
maybe the purple the vibrator she
brought on the first night we couldn't
see it was blurred out maybe it was
purple no but then why couldn't she wear
it forwards she wore it backwards with
the zipper in the front is her vibrator
have a zipper no but maybe it's like she
that way she can unzip easily for her
vibrator
but everyone missed that no i'm just i'm
just trying to understand well i'm glad
that katie's seeing the
hypocrisy in the budgets
post-production pre-productions right
next to each other are so [ __ ] funny
michelle is gorgeous and like i really
did enjoy that
it was kind of a reminder of like the
good the golden age of bachelor yes
because it was just like dripping and
opulence in the roses and they used to
be like highly anticipated and then
recently it's just been like less and
less and it's like who [ __ ] cares um
but they brought it back from shell so
that was nice yeah that was nice and it
definitely if you were on the fence
about watching like i could imagine this
would send you over the edge and i also
could imagine if you're katie this might
send you over the edge yeah she has a
funny attitude about it at the end of
the day she found love and she's happy
and that's what matters um and the fact
that she's in on the joke like kind of
makes me like her even though i really i
don't watch her season i know nothing
about her i just love people who can
like i feel like a lot of people like
they would see they would have you know
their horrible
problems they would see the girl after
them like literally two months later and
be like feel bitter about it and then
like on a podcast in a year like talk
[ __ ] about it totally
she just was like came out she came out
she's being honest like i'm here for it
actually you know what i totally agree
like i have major respect for that right
totally
so
that's exciting what was katie's song do
you remember
do you think i literally know anything
about what happened to katie usually the
song which little mixed song is it
however you want me
i think so yeah
i mean you can't go wrong with a little
mix song you just can't i just say the
little mix bops that have been dropping
no offense since jessie left are so good
that david get a song how does it go
heartbreak anthem
this ain't a heartbreak anthem i don't
care what happened
so [ __ ] good like i don't know maybe
jesse was holding them back the whole
time no see as someone who's been there
from the beginning really with these
girls the jessie
the songs were great
but with jessie's gone nothing has
changed that's what i've realized and
you know what that's very similar to
like when zane left the band like
honestly my favorite album from
one direction is the one where zane
wasn't in it yeah honestly five is too
many in a band four is a perfect amount
okay but now little mix is three a trio
how fabulous yeah no i agree like just
great can't be stopped a four-part
harmony like four is actually a great
number for not a band like a group
because bands play instruments but
no one little mix takes no time off like
every i followed the little mix account
on instagram and like literally every
week they're dropping a song for the
last five years but you know what they
two out of three of them just had babies
so i actually do you think now they
might be taking a small a small part it
feels like it's more than ever now no
because that song is everywhere the
heartbreak anthem it's so good like if
i'm not listening to that song seriously
in ibiza in the next six months like get
me out of here i think you missed your
season for ibiza i know what's coming up
um in the fall people go to
okay like take me to aspen oh no i can't
deal with that altitude anymore i'm
never going above sea level ever again
where do people go in the fall
maybe like an apple orchard
where como okay sure whatever no
actually i'm pretty sure like everyone
went to like homo in august but whatever
whatever the cool travel destination is
for fall like
put me there and put that song on and
like i'm just gonna show everyone my
tits like i just i think it's newport
oh yeah we've got up on our trip i know
okay our next story kanye west seems to
hint at cheating on kim kardashian after
two kids in new song hurricane okay i
totally missed this 100 missed it in his
new song hurricane which is featured on
his recently released 10th studio album
donda the rapper seemingly hints that he
cheated on his estranged wife kim after
welcoming their first children together
the lyrics go like this here i go acting
too rich here i go with a new chick and
i know what the truth is still playing
after two kids it's a lot to digest when
your life's always moving
then another wait okay it could also the
way that i perceive it it's written in
like a weird bizarre like third person
he could also be talking about kim
like kim chi did just devil's advocate
for a second that kim is acting too rich
kim has a new chick oh never mind
no but yeah maybe it's like that they're
in different intensities there's a big
rumor sorry about kim and drake yeah but
maybe sure say that's true whatever but
like
if their marriage was strained for so
many years like kanye probably got some
too of course so
still playing after two kids is that the
only line that references it
yeah but then later in the song which he
says this and i when i heard it i was
like okay so my accountability he was
like architectural digest but i needed
home improvement 60 million dollar home
never went home to it oh my god i love
that line
and you know there was an article in he
news yesterday and even when it comes to
the kardashians is pretty reliable
a source says that kim is open to the
possibility i just want to say now that
he lost the show they've become just as
bad as everyone else that's true
they reported kylie's pregnancy like
they used to not until it was like
direct from chris
but now they're just like another us
weekly when it comes to the kardashians
that's so true oh my god i didn't
realize that like
we no longer have actually now when i
think of kardashian like verified news i
think of tmz me too but that's just
because tmz does the work the other
outlets just regurgitate what the other
places are saying and like random
sources but like literally tmz is at the
courthouse they have every medical file
oh yeah if anything is in the courts he
has it but they're like living in the
trash cans living in a dumpster like in
the bushes like they're doing the work
that's so true that's why it's it's good
stuff yeah that's true but like i'm
sorry e news doesn't have people in the
dumpster no not at all they just like
wait to see what you know the wire
they wait to see what tmz pulls out of
the trash can
and then they regurgitate it like a day
later yeah okay that's so interesting
e-news no longer a reliable source for
kardashians i actually really agree with
that yeah it's not i mean it makes sense
they don't have the show anymore like
why would they like why would they stop
on reporting like things that
kardashians wouldn't want out there it's
september we're almost at 2022 like
where is the kardashian show
keep waiting i'm not even like waiting
for it yet i'm not even thinking about
it i feel like there's a chance they
haven't even started filming it i think
they are taking a true
break especially this summer like
everyone's on vacation living life i'm
just living life
um
and so
yeah i feel that don't even think i
don't even need like a piece of content
i would just like to know like what are
we gonna see what where do we watch it
is it weekly like i would just love some
some information some details some
structure you're not gonna get it no i'm
not so i i like for me personally when i
know i'm not gonna get what i want i
just have to like stop thinking about it
yeah you know otherwise it's a constant
disappointment yeah are you ready for
our fifth and final story
yeah
i am
are you
well
to catch 22. okay i'm only ready for the
next story if it's a story that's
brought to you by paypal yes then you're
ready when it's time to pay why pull out
your wallet or open your purse when you
probably already have your phone in your
hand paypal qr code payments are now
accepted at cvs stores nationwide so
it's super easy to make touch free
payments with your phone and you can get
ten dollars cash back on your first
purchase of 20 or more so honestly like
we're paypal's just kind of living in
the 21st century where we've all been in
the stone age like carrying around
wallets and usually when i go to um cvs
i'm always walking theo and i never
bring my phone and it's like oh i want a
water but i don't have my wallet so like
i always have my phone i never have my
wallet and now that you could pay
especially at cbs because i go to cbs
like four times a day now that you can
pay for
things on your phone with paypal it's so
genius
so it's just a qr code it's super easy
to use in just a few taps in the app
you're done you're paid you don't have
to deal with all the annoying change
pulling out a credit card and it works
with a cashier or at self checkout so if
you want to punch a checking uh a
checkout machine you can also use your
phone to pay which is huge and you can
use your phone to punch
plus you can get 10 cashback the first
time you make a purchase of 20 or more
it's like getting everything half off i
have used paypal online for purchases
for years but now i love how we can use
it in stores and we're getting the same
security also credit cards are low-key
like disgusting like they're covered in
bacteria those machines are like literal
cesspools so just have your phone easy
breezy to get the 10 cash back on your
first transaction of 20 or more head to
your local cvs and pay using the paypal
or the venmo app that's 10 cashback on
your first purchase of 20 or more with
the paypal or venmo app and to see terms
and learn about how you can earn the 10
cashback go go to paypal.com
toast you guessed it
sweet okay our fifth story is a little
collab business news calabadis club
business spotify is taking over delta's
entire in-flight audio section oh my god
it's about time with the radio like
spotify has announced that it's taking
over the audio section of delta's
inflight seat back entertainment by
offering its most popular playlists
along with 42 select podcast series
starting on september 1st while it
doesn't mean that you'll get random
access to all spotify content you'll get
a decent selection of popular music and
podcasts from the streaming service the
content is licensed directly by delta
and free for all passengers and includes
podcasts like crime junkie science for
startup the dave chang show the hottest
take the journal and more i just have to
say spotify stays winning like
they are
geniuses they are like they've been
buying up all these podcasts and now
they're gonna take people on a plane oh
you have nothing to do for six hours i'm
gonna force you to listen to one of my
podcasts it's literal the most genius
synergy or integration i don't know it's
so smart i'm sorry like you could be mad
but they're winning yeah you'll also get
access to some of their playlists like
mood booster r b hot country mint
today's top hits relax and unwind caviar
great playlist yeah rap caviar people
love that playlist too and people love
mood booster too yeah so
pretty cool synergy news
no it's so smart like it's every time
spotify does something like i'm sorry
they're just
they're the best in the biz and i'm
surprised like apple
apple like the small changes that they
do make are just making everything work
worse like the new brows and like like
every every podcast has a channel just
stop over complicating it yeah and they
like move the charts like the way bottom
and it's like that's the only thing you
guys have going is your chart because
like the charts are extremely telling
telling
and they they're updated frequently like
even the spotify look at their playlist
their podcasts and like they have the
top charts for shows and then for but
it's not very competitive episodes it's
just like they're not charty over there
and like spotify still like not they're
big but they're not the biggest in the
podcasting space apple is so like you
would trust an apple podcast chart i've
never checked a spotify podcast chart in
my life yeah so and then they just move
all that to the bottom it's like they
don't want people on the charts and it's
like that's one of your strengths apple
i would lean into it yeah i think apple
is losing at the spotify i mean at this
podcasting game so hard when they
literally invented podcasting and i
think in like
less maybe than five years
no one will be listening to podcasts on
spotify they're just [ __ ] the bed
they announced sorry on apple they
announced this huge update like
spotify's been doing all these amazing
things apple finally announced all these
things i'm reading it
okay i'm like who [ __ ] cares yes you
can offer
like a subscription on apple but do you
know
literally as a creator creator they take
an enormous percentage of your why would
anyone host a subscription service on
apple to give apple a part of their
percentage like you're monetizing your
own audience and giving money to apple
and the apple platform sucks like i'm
just every time they announce a new
update i'm like you guys are not reading
the room at all no when the apple
platform sucks like every single day we
post our podcast and when we post the
picture on to the instagram it means
that the
the audio and the video are both up
unless we specify that the video's not
up yet right every single day
and every single day there are people
who are like why is it on apple yet it's
like people because apple [ __ ] sucks
yeah apple sucks literally a few weeks
ago
apple took almost 24 hours to upload our
episode it was on spotify in a couple
minutes we upload through like a
back-end dashboard and they distribute
to all the platforms mostly people just
listen on spotify and apple and
literally and i put in the ticket with
podcast connect i'm like is something
broken for 24 hours like it can take up
to 24 hours it usually doesn't but i'm
like it can but i've also seen other
creators other podcasters who are like
it's not showing up on apple yet like
listen on spotify or if you subscribe on
apple you have a better chance of
getting it in your library than if you
don't subscribe but it's like just
[ __ ] fix it no like the most
fundamental part of the podcast app is
accessing podcasts and they can't even
do that yeah so honestly this whole
delta thing is genius i think that i'm
actually really surprised because as far
as i know the only airline that has a
partnership with the streaming service
is jetblue and jetblue isn't an enormous
airline it's really not even that
international um but none of like
american airlines united delta have
partnerships with like netflix and i'm
always surprised because you're stuck on
a plane if i just had a [ __ ] everyone
has to bring their ipad if the stupid tv
just had netflix like what a joy it
would be so i think this delta spotify
integration is actually going to be huge
and the the whole audio element
on planes is so broken i think up until
now the delta partnership has been with
siriusxm so you can go to the radio tab
of the tv and listen to like 40s on 40
50 on 50s and it's just not it at all no
and like when are your airpods going to
be able to connect to your entertainment
totally
i mean it would definitely be you know a
feat because then everyone's airpods pop
up
oh yeah
but it's 20 21. yeah so i'm sure there's
a way no and if there's not a way like
the
the headphones that they're passing out
are just not cutting it
oh no oh no oh no no no no no no no no
okay let's talk about real houses
beverly hills let's the dinner party
from hell i think that's so offensive
towards kathy hilton because i couldn't
agree more because it was heavenly it
was heavenly in there i was living for
every minute i mean the way some of the
women were behaving were it's like
really cringey and like embarrassing and
like they've never been to a nice place
lisa right now these are even like dorit
a little bit sorry you love her so much
sorry no but honestly this was not a
good episode for dream well it wasn't it
wasn't first of all i wasn't a fan of
pigtails at the most elegant dinner
party we've ever seen i wasn't a fan of
like literally giving me kyle and
shahida vibes with her [ __ ] fake ass
wedding dresses like this is real
housewives of beverly hills i'm sorry we
we are beyond stupid ass this was salt
lake city fashion show like
we are beyond these little projects like
these women the hiltons like we are
beyond these little projects i'm sorry
like even beverly beach was dumb like
i'm sorry she's allowed to work on her
thing no of course but like her trying
on these three dresses were so pretty
when there's so much else going on
the dresses were pretty i thought it
actually showcased like a cute dynamic
between her and pk i was not offended by
any of it not offended i just thought
like we are above this i enjoyed that
scene considering it was like a personal
home scene which usually i don't enjoy
okay i did not okay so there so we
disagree that's crazy
if anything else happened oh the only
other thing that happened in the episode
before we get to the dinner party is
crystal had everyone over to talk [ __ ]
about something oh what the [ __ ] was
that what was that from crystal
really i forgot that they hated each
other that they had that i know because
you know what
they were they said they put it behind
them but then like everything came out
of like how crystal really feels about
sutton when she was around one person
who also doesn't like sudden which was
erica and also loki kathy well kathy was
just basically being like you're so
worried about your reputation don't
worry nobody knows who you are and then
crystal and it's okay for kathy hilton
to say [ __ ] like that but then krista
was like yeah i don't know who she is so
we don't know who you were either
crystal like relax crystal like also
said that when she first came on yeah
she said that about dorit and that seems
to be like her
measure for like if someone is worthy
and i just
i think it's kind of low and it's
hypocritical because
kathy hilton can say [ __ ] like that
crystal we hadn't heard of you
maybe some people had heard of your
husband now we hit garcia said right and
i'm so glad garcelle pointed that out
like
i'm sorry
you can't say [ __ ] like that if you're
not like you're not a household name
also just because you haven't heard of
someone doesn't mean that their opinions
don't matter or that they're not allowed
to be concerned with their name or this
that and the other thing and also
something that
colored my view of the episode last
night was this unseen moment that bravo
cut out but they act but they put in
like unseen scenes at the at the meeting
with at the meeting at dorit's house
when sutton got everyone together to
talk about erica it's a really big piece
of information it's a really big piece
of information sutton shared that when
eric was first going through her divorce
that
as sutton had been through a divorce her
lawyer said to her you know you might
need someone who can lean on for money
you know they'll pay you back after but
like you might need some money right now
so sutton said to erica like when she
had just initially gotten divorced she
said you know i knew that my my lawyer
said this if you ever need
me to be that person i will be that
person for you right so we don't know if
she ended up giving her money i don't
think she did right but so i i just
think like sutton is entitled to feel
how she wants to feel where i'm losing
sutton is she's a big bad mamma jamma
talking to everyone and then she talks
to erica and she's like
that
yes and no i think the way that we're
seeing it yes it's like she says she's
big voice when she's not with erica but
then she gets to sit with erica and
nobody [ __ ] lets her speak and maybe
she's being long-winded because she's
trying to couch what she's saying the
ultimate message she's trying to make it
sound
less harsh which i can i think it's like
not necessarily too faced and then she
has rinna and kyle saying be honest and
she's trying to [ __ ] speak and no one
will let her know i'm sorry kyle i do
think was justified like literally she
said in her backyard too kyle she was
like
i am gonna tell her straight to her face
i don't believe her blah blah blah
you're a liar and then she's just
getting there and they're having the
conversation for a while and sutton
never lands the plane and she's like no
like i i i support you and kyle's like
what the [ __ ] i'm sorry i actually
really appreciated kyle like if you're
going to take a stand take a stand i
just think we're not seeing the whole
conversation because i really it's too
confusing and also like sutton is not
backing down even when erica talks to
her like she's the literal [ __ ] on her
shoe erica has to stop doing that like
erica's behavior last night completely
turned me off to her
even wanting to try and find out like
what she did or didn't know like
that's just not how you speak to people
and also like just be like these people
are your friends and and if they weren't
you'd [ __ ] know it but there doesn't
mean they're not allowed to ask you a
question about like the biggest thing
that's going on in town right now right
because erica is like
you're to re you're torturing me with
this torturing it's everywhere like
what are we supposed to do not talk
about it right
it's so stupid and it's like i don't
know what the right way to go about this
is like definitely not the lisa written
a blind loyalty moronic way of going
about it i feel like the person who has
the most
realistic outlook on it is probably kyle
um by the way did you think it was weird
that kathy's like go-to butler didn't
know who kyle was he did think that she
was like i'm kyle i'm kathy's sister i
just feel like they're not close i don't
know but i think the person has the most
realistic outlook on it is garcelle and
when she said last night like
and no one has any like the women keep
saying and when someone else brings up
the orphans and widows they're like yes
of course
no one is mentioning them like garcelle
was like these people had nothing and
now they have less like totally where is
the energy for that no and this victim
mentality from erica is really starting
to bother me like crying at every meal
and make like look at my life what about
the life of people whose parents died in
a plane and they literally got no money
what about their lives i'd like to look
at their lives because they seem a lot
worse than you living in your casita
like you're fine yeah i couldn't agree
more like everyone has lost sight of
everything and it just looks like
erica's gonna
like
get away with all of this i think erica
will i think
you know even even if she didn't know
like whatever no one's gonna push her on
anything she's made it impossible to
raise an eyebrow and i think even in the
legal system i don't think she's gonna
go to jail or anything because it's all
about like what did she
know or didn't know and there's really
no way to prove that unless like you
know there's a paper show but i don't
think that there is so i think that you
know tom is probably going to jail um i
don't think
tom's not going to jail because of his
he's too old like it's it's they don't
send people that old to jail i think
it's like illegal why they sent like
harvey weinstein
harry white seems like in his 60s or 70s
no he but tom jordy is like literally 1
000 years old okay no let's see the
difference no okay remember in shawshank
redemption that guy gets out because
he's old yes and then very sad yes you
can like i understand what you're saying
at a certain point you're not allowed to
go to prison i'm telling you i don't
know what the rule is i don't make a
party harvey weinstein is 69.
thomas in his 90s i think he's in his
80s tell me and also one other thing tom
jordy's 82. um
he's looking a lot older than that yeah
he wants you to think that so that he's
that's part of his defense one other
thought that i had and i think it was
like something amongst what sutton said
was like eric and tom were married for
20 years
in the same month that eric decides to
divorce tom is the same month that his
whole
life is about to crumble it's so
fake i'm sorry like
i if i had if i'm being really cynical
and thinking about what happened it's
that they knew that this was coming
and erica's running for cover of course
not like oh we happen to get divorced
and then a month later it happened that
he's like the world's worst criminal
it's an amazing point the odds of not
even the same month one week apart like
the odds of the divorce and the lawsuit
coming out in the same week agreed when
they've been married for 20 years it's
too weird and i just feel like all of
these women
are worried that erica is gonna be fine
like she'll move on with her life she'll
build her life back up she'll go back to
being you know the favorite beverly
hills housewife and then she's gonna
hate you because literally five years
ago you questioned on whether or not she
stole money from orphans so that's where
darita is now she's like no i support
you but also jared is like you know the
audience [ __ ] hates erica the
audience is not standing for this at all
the audience the audience stands with
sutton and the audience thinks erica
knew everything so it's like which side
do you play like you want to be popular
you know when your instagram comments be
flooded with like you are supporting
a mongrel but also like you have to
survive with these women and if erica
doesn't like you like she makes it very
known like she is [ __ ] annihilating
sutton and it's like even though sutton
has
decent intentions and sudden like has
fair points she doesn't even get to them
because she's getting
annihilated by erica
so eric is impossible to talk to and
this is an impossible situation for the
women she's like do i support my friend
and maybe down the line she won't kill
me or do i ask like the ethical
questions and have the audience be
behind me
erica i mean lisa arena has made it
abundantly clear like she doesn't give a
[ __ ] if the audience likes her anymore
which is crazy because that's all she
cared about forever yeah but i think
what she does care about is being on the
show right and being in the good graces
of the women and never being at a
position where like you're kind of out
of the group that you could be like cut
out of the show yeah
because at some point if you're just not
really friends with anyone and you're
like boring that's grounds for firing
like if you're like on the outskirts
so
the dinner party continues next week
it's just
we didn't get a preview though
did we not no it just like went into the
show so good the lamb chops oh my god
caviar pie yum yeah it was like egg
caviar pie it looked so good like the
house was so stunning the decor was
those baccarat like lamps everyone was
like and the gl like just everything to
a tea and it's like
and we thought beverly hills was creme
de la creme and like we were missing out
on such creme
the creme of the creme the cremi vibes
no it was so good and i just i really do
like love kathy i love her i totally
misread her in the beginning of the
season i thought that she was
all over the place and she's not at
all those episodes back and just see if
maybe she was all over the place or if
like there was just a side of her that
like now matches up to like the woman
that we know or yeah that we're getting
to know
she is and
it's just it's a pleasure
it's a pleasure
that is our show and it was a pleasure
um anything else you want to say before
we wrap it up no but check out the
redheads if you're missing us already
you know you can read the book or not
read the book we always do a summary at
the beginning so you'll know what we're
talking about and we're just talking
about major themes in life you know
family love honesty secrets
can you ever keep a secret and never
tell anyone and it cause and it's better
that way and no harm done
or does everything have to get out in
the open eventually everything comes out
in the wash i really do believe that
you can keep a secret but it'll eat you
up and then you'll become like a
miserable little [ __ ] i mean i didn't
read the book i don't know what it's
about but it sounds like it sounds like
a nailed it
that actually is the book yeah
thank you guys so much for listening to
the morning toast the millennium morning
show where we deliver the fast five
stories that you need to know every
monday through friday on youtube so if
you're watching this on youtube please
feel free to subscribe and give this
video a thumbs up we're also available
as a podcast and where podcasts can be
found inside spotify itunes stitcher
public radio i heart video cast box all
the places so whenever you listen to
podcasts find us the morning shows and
leave a five-star review about how
beautiful stunning
and smart we are hope you an amazing day
it's been a pleasure if you're still
here listening leave the emoji on our
most recent instagram of just like the
cardboard box like i'm just feeling boxy
have a great day everyone will see you
tomorrow bye